the social media crackdown giving
democratic politicians a big boost over
their republican rivals
that's according to axios here i'm
quoting the combined twitter following
for the 10 elected democrats with the
biggest audiences
is 102 million compared to 23 million
for the top 10 republicans and
conservatives are taking notice of a new
poll
it says the biggest concern among
democrats
trump supporters they're worried about
trump's supporters
well uh greg let me start with you on
the twitter numbers i mean it's fun to
look at the comparing numbers democrats
republicans
but isn't there a simple answer here
trump's off twitter
that could be part of it but there's
also something else going on
if you look at twitter trends they're
driven by online mob
actions for example you could see
whether it's tucker or glenn greenwald
or fox and friends
it's never because they love you it's
because there's a directed manipulated
cycle of repetitive destruction
and so you just say you just decide you
know what i'm not going to be there
and what you're seeing now is the fourth
leg of the table being
controlled you had academia you had
media and entertainment now it's social
media
and when you and when you say look
they're obviously right now eradicating
dissent
the response is no but twitter is
private and facebook is private that's
no longer an argument because there is
no public option
the only public option you have is
shouting in a park which i do daily
the private sensors private censorship
on social media now is just purely
censorship of speech
because you still can make laws for
private companies
if you walk outside human resources you
see all the laws on there
what's against the law we're gonna have
to start thinking about this because
right now
people are getting pushed out of out of
i guess what i would call
the town square and they have nowhere
else to go except shouting in the town
square
okay jesse i was thinking about that
poll
indicated that democrats are worried
about trump supporters
do you think they're worried because of
what happened january 6th and
the concern is it could happen again and
you don't see many republicans speaking
out against it
well if that's the case they're idiots
they're really worried about
little old me they care more about who
their neighbor voted for that they care
about
i don't know taxes their kids go into
school
their jobs wages china
all of those things democrats don't care
as much about
as they care about some guy down the
street that pulled the lever for trump
that's insane juan i mean that is
collective
insanity and the second and third most
things they're concerned about
are systemic racism and white supremacy
it's all isms all they care about is
isms if you go to the republican poll
top concern is illegal immigration
second is
law and order and third is high taxes so
republicans care about issues
not isms i i just think you guys are
obsessed
and it's gotten strange now and
everything is driven by hatred
and emotion and if you could just relax
and think about policy
maybe we could get together and do
something for the american people
all right so martha picking up on that
uh
there was a recent poll that said 61
percent of trump's supporters 38 percent
of republicans say democrats
are bad people and out to destroy the
country
so is that the flip side of this picture
we're just polarized
yeah i mean it's a lot smaller than the
82 percent that are
you know obsessed with trump supporters
and
and i think jesse's exactly right i
think we have gotten to this point where
there is this kind of
derangement syndrome that takes up too
much space when there's a lot of other
things that we really need to be
concerned about
in this country and i think that poll is
very reflective in terms of where
people's
focus is and i understand what you say
about january the 6th and i think that
that was a very um
difficult day across the board but i
think that you know we need to focus on
the future of the country and where
things are headed i also think there's a
there's an interesting maybe
undercurrent in that number who are very
concerned about the trump support
because they also see what happened on
the on the congressional level on the
state legislature level
they're worried i think in some ways
that some of those people who supported
president trump
are pulling away from the democratic
party that they left them with
a lot more support in a lot of different
areas in congress a very close
match in congress i think picked up
about 12 13 seats so
you know that undercurrent that they've
lost the working class that they're
losing the blue-collar worker
i think that's a big concern about trump
supporters for a lot of democrats as
well
so judge jeanine i i was thinking that a
lot of it stemmed from january 6th what
do you think
i i really don't think it's about
january 6th i think it's about the fact
that the democrats recognize
that the trump supporters are dug in
and solid and they're unwavering in
their support for this man
it's the trump supporters who went you
know 35
000 in in in 10 degree temperature 50
000 you know where you know for joe
biden there are a couple in a circle
uh the truth is that they know that
martha's right
that they're losing the blue collar that
they knew it from the first day that joe
biden went in
and did the executive order destroying
the xl keystone pipeline
i mean just have this visual of these
workers uh you know with their lunch
pails
being told your job 11 000 of you so far
is
gone and so there is a belief
system it is more than politics and it's
more than even hatred
there is a belief system in the trump
supporter that
this is the america that we want it
isn't even about the issues although
we're
more policy oriented they're more
identity politics oriented
the issue is america who we are from
whence we come and where we go in the
future
that's what the trumpers are about
okie doke